andrea nahles hat am sonntag ihren
rücktritt als spd partei und als
fraktionsvorsitzender angekündigt in
einem schreiben an die spd-mitglieder
schrieb sie die diskussion in der
fraktion und die vielen rückmeldungen
aus der partei haben mir gezeigt dass
der zur ausübung meiner ämter
notwendigen rückhalt nicht mehr da ist
am montag werde sie als partei am
dienstag als fraktionsvorsitzende
zurücktreten
sie wolle damit die möglichkeit eröffnen
dass sind beiden funktionen in
geordneter weise die nachfolge geregelt
werden könne
zuletzt war vor allem nach dem geringen
ergebnis der spd bei den europawahlen am
kritik an alles laut geworden sie hatte
im april 2018 den parteivorsitz
übernommen die fraktion führte sie seit
september 2017 ihrem nachfolger oder
ihre nachfolgerin wünschten alles in
ihrem schreiben glück und erfolg an ihre
parteikollegen appellierte sie bleibt
beieinander und handelt besonnen unser
land braucht eine starke spd